this is another example of how our
culture has just lost its moorings it's
like well what's life
well
you have a job or a career and hopefully
you're productive and you contribute
something to the community and you
provide yourself and your family with
the necessities of life that's a quarter
of your life or a third of it something
like that
you have an intimate relationship
you have a family
that's life
and if you don't have one of those
that's one third of your life you don't
have now some people maybe they're doing
so well on the other two fronts
that they can cope with not having that
or maybe they're doing so well on one
front they can cope with not having two
of them compensates yeah maybe
it's pretty hard because if you want to
have a great career
it's hard to do that if you're alone in
without a family
right i mean the the people that i've
seen who've been best situated in their
life all things considered
even in relationship to their career
have a pretty solid monogamous
relationship that stabilizes them and
then they have a family that also
stabilizes them and broadens out their
life and
you know exceptional people do
exceptional things and good for them but
they're
by definition given that they're
exceptional they're a tiny minority that
this is always the argument between
conservatives and liberals right because
the liberal types they're more tilted
sometimes towards
what would you call it uh
uh
compassion or appreciation for the
exceptional and fair enough the
exceptional is necessary but
on average
what everyone does on average is the
thing to do and so you just look you see
well what do people do well if they have
a job or career
they have an intimate relationship
and they have a family and if you don't
have
any one of those things well then you're
treading water harder doesn't mean you
can't do it and it doesn't even mean
possibly that you shouldn't try but
as a default
presumption it's just utterly
foolish
what else are you gonna do with your
life well maybe you're wildly creative
fair enough you know
that's extraordinarily rare as well
subject to the power law problem in any
case which is even if you're hyper
creative the probability that you're
going to be successful at that
economically is extremely
extremely tiny to the point where it's
almost non-existent it's so difficult
now it does happen and some and you can
have spectacular success if you become
successful but wasn't it did you say
last night
of the 100 000 most recently printed
books only a thousand have sold more
than a million yeah something like that
it's something powerless all the way
down yeah everywhere everywhere power
law that's you know a tiny minority of
people do all the work a tiny minority
of people get all the benefit a tiny
minority of athletes score all the goals
a tiny minority of men get all the women
etcetera a tiny minority of stars have
all the mass a tiny minority of rivers
have all the water a tiny minority of
cities have all the people etc etc etc
everywhere always
you know and and we're so clueless in
our culture that we blame that on
capitalism it's like
how does that account for the mass of
stars people
so or the you know the volume of rivers
or the population density of cities or
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace